سواء أكان إنفاق ملايين
الدولارات للتجول في أعالي البحار على متن
يخت ضخم أو التحليق عبر السماء على متن
طائرة خاصة، فإن أسلوب حياة Jet Set يدور
حول البهجة والسحر، ولكن عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالبيئة، هناك بعض
الأشياء التي لا يمكن حتى للمال أن يفعلها.
ليس من السهل الشراء جيدًا، فنحن نرى الكثير من الأشخاص
يختارون الطيران الخاص، ولكن أعتقد أننا
بحاجة إلى تبني مفهوم
الاستدامة، لذلك عندما تفكر في
هذا في سياق الطيران الخاص،
يمكنك تخيل جميع
التطبيقات المختلفة للوسائل الاجتماعية والاقتصادية.
الفوائد الاقتصادية التي تنتجها الصناعة
ولكن من أجل احتضان السلع التي
نحتاج إلى فهمها والحد من
الآثار البيئية السلبية
هو المؤسس والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة jetx التي لديها
أكثر من 30 محطة حول العالم،
وتعمل الشركة التي تتخذ من دبي مقراً لها جنباً إلى جنب مع
العشرات من  أسماء كبيرة أخرى في
مجال الطيران لتحقيق الهدف الطموح الذي حدده
الاتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي للوصول إلى صافي انبعاثات كربونية صفرية
بحلول عام 2050.
أول ما سيتبادر إلى ذهني
عائلتي وأطفالي وأحفادي،
حسنًا، كيف سيكون العالم في
العشرينيات القادمة  30 40 عامًا كيف يمكننا العمل
مع الجميع لجعل
تغير المناخ أقل تأثيرًا على حياتنا
ومستقبلنا؟
يمكن أن تكون الطائرات الخاصة أكثر تلويثًا بنسبة 5 إلى 14 مرة
من الطائرات التجارية وأكثر
تلويثًا بـ 50 مرة من القطارات
وفقًا لبيانات من شركات أوروبية
غير أوروبية.  -النقل والبيئة مربحان ولكن
الخطوات الصغيرة تؤدي ببطء إلى
تغييرات كبيرة في القطاع، لقد
بدأنا بالفعل في تحويل جميع
مستوطناتنا حول العالم إلى
محطة خضراء، وسنبدأ بأربعة مواقع
لتكون خضراء بالكامل، وقد تم
الكشف عن خطط في العام الماضي لإطلاق ما
إنها تطلق أول
محطة خاصة خضراء نقية تمامًا في العالم في
مطار نو هاردنبورغ في برلين والذي يعد موطنًا لواحدة
من أكبر مزارع الطاقة الشمسية في أوروبا.
كما تقوم الشركة الآن بتأجير طائرات
لا تضر بالبيئة
أثناء استكشاف استخدام
الطاقة الكهربائية  الطائرات ومن خلال
الشراكة مع شركة النفط الفنلندية، تقوم
بنشر
وقود الطيران المستدام المصنوع من
النفايات المتجددة والمواد الخام المتبقية
التي توقعنا أن 60 إلى 70 بالمائة
من تخفيضات الانبعاثات ستأتي من
تكامل وقود الطيران المستدام
ولكن إمكانية الوصول إليه اليوم محدودة
لذلك  إنه غير متوفر في كل مطار،
ونود أن نرى الطيران الخاص
يتحرك بسرعة أكبر بشأن اعتماد
وقود الطيران المستدام لأن ذلك
يمكن أن يخلق وفورات الحجم التي
يمكن أن تجعل الأمر في متناول الجميع ويسهل
على القطاعات الأخرى التحرك بعد ذلك
لدمج الإشعاع المستدام  الوقود
لذلك في حين أن رفاهية الطيران الخاص
هي تجربة من المرجح أن تتصدر
قائمة قوائم معظم المسافرين، فإن
شركات مثل jetex تتحمل الآن
المسؤولية النهائية المتمثلة في التأكد من أن
راحة الطيران الخاص يمكن أن
تكون مستدامة أيضًا
[موسيقى]